[Música]
hay una técnica para disminuir el miedo
y la pena y scott y es concentrarse en
una persona del público y dedicar toda
la atención esta charla es para ustedes
mis amigos quienes han estado a mi lado
en los últimos años para mí ha sido más
fácil la vida gracias a nuestra amistad
y gran conexión gracias por todo y esta
charla es para ustedes
bullying una palabra una acción un
problema una lucha para mí fue una
oportunidad para crecer aprender y
fortalecer mis debilidades y liderar en
lo que se ha convertido en uno de los
más grandes proyectos en mi vida en el
colegio
yo sufrí de bullying en el colegio quién
no
el proyecto que les vengo a hablar hoy
es el producto de años de reflexión y
trabajo que se consolida en un modelo
que busca reducir los casos de bullying
en el ambiente escolar partiendo de
cuatro cosas concretas prevención e
interpretación perdón y reconciliación
prevención por medio de charlas que
permitan la aceptación y el respeto de
las diferencias
interpretación al entender los
diferentes casos de bullying que se
presentan en el colegio creo que la
falta de matices en la lectura de los
casos y situaciones de bullying es un
paso fundamental para actuar de manera
efectiva
por último perdón y reconciliación
cuando se presentó un caso de bullying
debe buscar conectar a la víctima y el
agresor con todos los actores relevantes
para después hacer una rápidamente una
resolución efectiva del conflicto que
lleva al perdón ya la reconciliación
les voy a contar cómo empezó todo toda
mi vida es una persona muy introvertida
no solo contar mi vida personal así está
así que esta charla no es anecdótica ni
tampoco busco hacerme la víctima ni
sentirme el pobrecito lo hago porque
quiero ser porque quiero ser un agente
de cambio
no es fácil entender por qué te molestan
tampoco es fácil contener todas tus
fuerzas de furia cuando te hacen sentir
como una persona que está fuera del
lugar así llegan a sentir las personas
cuando sufren bullying a mí
particularmente me molestaban por cantar
y me decían todos los apodos que ustedes
se puedan imaginar
y esto me hacía sentir solo sé que
muchos de ustedes han vivido esto y
saben que la frustración que trae pero
que le digan a uno que tú tienes que
cambiar y no ellos yo siempre me
preguntaba por qué yo
entender esta experiencia y hablar de
ella me ha permitido trascender mi
propia realidad y usar mi experiencia me
permitió identificar qué parte del
bullying tiene qué parte del bullying
los actores del bullying son las
personas involucradas en el conflicto
aunque el conflicto y la otra parte
tiene que ver con las personas que
intervienen en el conflicto esto no es
un juicio sobre cómo se manejan los
procesos de bullying en los colegios he
aprendido que las herramientas que se
usan parten del principio de la buena fe
sin embargo creo que los estudiantes
involucrados deben ser una parte activa
en la solución del conflicto lo más
importante que me di cuenta cuando
empecé a pensar en este proyecto fue
entender que las personas tienen buenas
intenciones y eso fue fundamental para
poder pensar en cómo la mediación podía
ser más efectiva
creo que es importante que las personas
que han sufrido el bullying alguna vez
puedan reinterpretar su frustración
cuando sienten que no son escuchadas
hacer esto me llevó a entender tres
puntos cruciales
primero que eran las herramientas las
que no funcionaban y no las personas
segundo y aprovechó para hacer una
aclaración este punto no lo hubiera
logrado sin de no haber sido por mi
familia que siempre me ha confiado en mí
y me ha apoyado tuve que aprender a
acercarme a la gente de una manera
diferente a desarrollar y aprender
nuevas habilidades de liderazgo para
poder proponer una solución pero lo más
importante que tuve que hacer fue
creerme el cuento que yo era una persona
muy importante y valiosa y que tenía en
mis manos el poder de generar un cambio
al hablar de esta propuesta que me ha
tomado meses desarrollar muy cuenta que
más allá de que se implemente o no hay
un valor profundo y una invitación a
pensar que la posibilidad de ser agentes
de cambio es necesaria más allá que para
nosotros mismos más para nosotros mismos
que para la comunidad al pensar y soñar
en esta propuesta he sido yo quien ha
cambiado y por eso ya tiene sentido este
fue mi punto de partida
yo sabía que la solución tenía que salir
de manos de personas que verdaderamente
han sentido y vivido las consecuencias
del bullying yo sabía que no podía
esperar a que las cosas cambiaran tenía
que explotar todo mi potencial y sabía
que al hacer esto iba a volar en un
cielo sin nubes un cielo lleno de
esperanza
liderar esta propuesta no solo me ha
llevado a entender que hay personas que
se preocupan por mí que me quieren y que
tienen también la voluntad de
acompañarme en el camino hacia
solucionar este problema
y desarrollarla me ha llevado a cargar
más sonrisas y risas en mi vida me ha
ayudado a buscar mis fortalezas a sacar
lágrimas de alegría y además me
convirtió en un ser humano mucho más
guerrero
esta propuesta es un cambio de
mentalidad que llevará mucho tiempo si
las medidas contra el bullying
funcionarán este simplemente no
existiría por esta razón bus que desde
el primer momento trascender la visión
punitiva que tienen los colegios para
controlar los casos de bullying por lo
tanto el eje central de esta iniciativa
es entender los casos de bullying desde
una mirada integral para que no sólo los
dos actores puedan tener un apoyo y
puedan reconciliarse en buenos términos
sino para la no repetición
de los casos de bullying hoy he hablado
de una propuesta y el tiempo sobre el
proceso y el impacto que he tenido mi
vida a pensar y desarrollo y soñar en un
cambio
espero que este camino que hoy he
compartido y que a mí me ha servido para
sanar sirva para dejar una huella quiero
que no se repitan actos que transgredan
otra persona quiero romper la reacción
en cadena por último quiero compartir
las palabras de este del cantante yuri
buenaventura que me ha servido de
inspiración para para mantenerme firme y
no dar un paso atrás y también para las
otras personas que están viendo esta
charla
el guerrero
levantó su mano
señalando
hacia el infinito
el guerrero
dice que estas lágrimas
y son la red
del mañana que me espera
el guerrero
sin miedo fue
buscando
hermandad
buscando fortaleza
con el alma
con el alma lee
y a
con la
sonrisa
con la sonrisa
y para finalizar apagar el fuego de otra
persona no te hace brillar más muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]